today there's going to be literally a
thousand threads that are Charlie Monger
was lived till 99 here's 99 lessons I
learned and they're going to regurgitate
the stupid quotes in Wikipedia but this
is my first we do things differently
around here we're not just G to give you
the regurgitated quotes I got to give
you that you know little special jeo
that oldo that you could dip that
sandwich
[Music]
in all right Charlie Munger has died at
age 99 and all around the world people
are remembering Charlie this guy who's
Warren Buffett's business partner he's a
billionaire but he's so much more than
that he was a guy who uh he was in the
military uh he dropped out of school
went to the military then he somehow
talked his way into Harvard Law even
though he didn't even have an under
undergraduate degree um you know he
started a law firm that people don't
even ever talk about that's you know do
hundreds of millions in Revenue uh he
you know started investing with Warren
Buffett and has basically outperformed
the stock market over like a 50-year
period by a huge degree and um you know
Bill Gates called uh Charlie you know
maybe the broadest thinker he knows he
said that um he has the best 30 second
brain of anybody he's ever met and we
wanted to dissect that brain what's
inside that what made Charlie so
prolific why did Warren Buffett say that
Burkshire is shaped uh in the mold of
Charlie Munger and that he is one of the
you know the smartest and wisest men
he's ever met um and we pulled out seven
of the Big Ideas Charlie said a lot of
things over the years but we we
identified what we think are the seven
big big bits of wisdom uh that Charlie
has shared and what we wanted to do was
instead of just making a listicle which
you're going to see a lot today you're
see people on Twitter you know every
thread boy is going to be like Charlie
mugger died at 99 here's the 99 bits of
wisdom and they're G to copy paste
Wikipedia we didn't want to do that what
we wanted to do was take the seven that
we thought were really really impactful
and specifically tell a story of how
that's happened you how we how we
learned that lesson in our own bu
business life or in our life um it made
for I think a pretty amazing episode I
told Sam I said dude this uh this notes
document uh that we have for this
episode thing is you got a handkerchief
this thing is dripping with wisdom and
you're that's how you're gonna feel at
the end of this podcast you're gonna
need to take a shirt you're gonna need
to wipe the old podcast player because
this episode is about to be dripping
with wisdom I hope you enjoy this
episode on the seven bits of wisdom from
Charlie
Monger so let's jump into the wisdom so
what I I think would be fun is we just
sort of trade our favorites because this
guy's got hundreds of little Charlie
isms uh you know uh little little quips
or or quotes about the way the world
Works about the way minds work about the
way the markets work and I just thought
it' be great to just like pull out you
know this is trade you go first and then
I'll go on you know some of our
favorites and either I think we can just
you know talk about them or share you
know a way that we've e we've either
heard him talk about it or how played a
role in our life all right you go first
okay um I I'll start with a very easy
one so one of you know one of his big
Ideas is to get what you want you need
to deserve what you want and so he says
you know the easiest way to get
everything that you want is to deserve
it and it's so simple that it's almost
like obnoxiously simple this advice uh
but he's like whether it's the like you
know if you want the partner you want
you should be deserving of that level of
partner right make yourself worthy of a
partner like that uh same thing with
Investments he kind of actually calls
out a few things that money can't buy so
he's like um trust in other people uh
success and admiration those are things
you cannot buy you can only earn and so
if you want somebody's admiration
deserve it if you want somebody's trust
deserve it if you want success deserve
it and uh I'll share like a very simple
more practical anecdote about this
because again like his big ideas are
amazing but they just sort of float in
the clouds unless you bring it to earth
with like a real tactical example so
when we sold the milk Road I've said
this before but one of the reasons we we
sold to the guys we did was I really
really respected these guys it was not
the highest offer but these were the
highest quality people that we could
sell to and we just had a hunch that
like selling to the highest quality
people will result in the best long-term
outcome and even if every even if like
you know we lose a dollar today um
actually just being in business with
these guys is going to create you know
for every we're taking less today we
might create three more dollars in the
future just by being around high quality
people and I'll tell you a story that
came out of the due diligence that like
was like a nugget of gold that stuck
with me that was exactly this so these
guys that we were selling to uh had
built businesses that one of the guys
had sold his businesses for about 90 to
100 million and the other guy had sold
his business for over 200 million and
both of them had built businesses that
were SEO based and I know a lot of
things about marketing and growth but I
know zero about SEO I am an ABS absolute
beginner novice I never touch SEO I
don't do businesses that are SEO based I
literally know nothing and so one of the
ways I priced in the deal was oh I'm
Gonna Learn SEO from these guys who were
frankly Masters at SEO and so we get to
the point where we do the deal I've
built up you know that we're not
negotiating anymore and I'm like oh good
I'm gonna start digging I'm gonna start
picking these guys brains for SEO
like tell them and so I sat them down I
was like you're going to teach me about
SEO now and they started to tell me
something but I was like okay okay
that's the general stuff I've heard that
stuff before
like what's the like real like Master
what's the real like you know black
belt that I don't know about that
you can't just Google and read and you
know some blog that like helped you guys
create you know one guy created um the
number one search result for if you say
I want to buy gold online and that's the
business that was you know sold for a
few hundred million dollars that he
bootstrapped that you know never raised
any money and he did it because he knew
how to be the top result for Buy Gold
Online how'd you do it bro what' you do
was it some some hack some technique
and he's like um you know we did all the
normal things and he's like and I tried
some of these hacker techniques it
didn't really work and he's like so then
he's like you know what happened was one
day I Googled how to buy gold online and
we were the fifth result at the time he
goes so what I did was I clicked the
link I he's like I just you know thought
to myself what does Google really want
Google wants to give you the best search
result meaning if somebody searches for
how to buy gold online they want you to
to get to a page that's going to answer
those questions and not have you go
search again he's like so then I printed
out all five of the results us being
number five and I printed one through
four also and I sat down for an hour and
I just looked at them and I read them
and I was like I had an honest
conversation with myself of why would I
click on my page what is better about my
page than these other pages and I was
like wait so you didn't like do some
like black hat SEO that was like
this like Advanced trick yeah why AR why
aren't you using the word Ai and he was
like no he's like we didn't deserve the
click we weren't better Pages he so he's
like so all I did for the next year was
every week I printed out all the pages
and then I made my page like you know
10% better I figured out one way that we
could be better as objectively better
even if we weren't moving up in the
ranks yet that I could look at it and
say this is a better page we deserve to
be higher ranked and I had literally
never heard this and I was like on one
hand in the moment honestly I was kind
of disappointed I was like dude I came
to you for that secret Ju you about SEO
like I'm not trying to have this like
you got to work hard and and just
actually make a better page but it was
also kind of like refreshing it's like
you go to the people who are masters of
SEO and they're like yeah you can do all
the tricks but at the end of the day you
have to have the best result like you
have to have the best page and you have
to have an honest conversation with
yourself of is your page better than
these other Pages he's like if you
really want to sustainably like climb
the Rings and be at number one that's it
and that was such a like tangible
business example of like to get what you
want you have to deserve what you want
and um I'll never forget get that that
was like one of the biggest takeaways I
had of the whole process that's
beautiful our software is the worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better all right
if you're loving this episode I'm glad I
also want to tell you three things that
we are doing as a podcast quick little
news flash news announcement about MFM I
have three things to tell you here they
are number one there's like this Meetup
thing going on so uh this is kind of
cool so um there's a woman do you
remember her name I sorry I'm not
remember her name the top of my head
Rachel I think it is I think her name's
Rachel um sorry Rachel if it's not
Rachel uh that's all right she runs a
company she runs a company that
basically helps like contact creators
like a spin up Meetup so basically
what's happening is in a couple weeks
we'll put the link in the in the
description I'll also tweet it out but
uh in like a week or two around the
world there's MFM meetups which is kind
of fun we're not going to be there
because it's like you know they're
they're all happening on the same day in
different locations but forget us if
you're one of these people that listen
to the podcast you're probably going to
get along with other people who listen
to the podcast it's just like a thing uh
you know like people who listen to this
podcast you're business nerds with a
sense of humor and if you like business
nerds with a sense of humor they're all
getting together everybody's going to
like a a bar you know like there's one
in Toronto there's one in California
there's one in Austin and they're
they're going to hang out it's called
River so you go to get
river. so get GE and then River like a
stream river. you scroll all the way to
the bottom and you'll see my first
million Meetup there's um they're
happening in Austin in Houston Denver
Nashville Atlanta Cincinnati all all
over the North America I believe right
oh her name's Ray you were right okay so
Ry uh move us to the top for this week
because we got a oh here we go so my
first million so so yeah uh they did
this for all in I think and that's kind
of one one of the proof of Concepts um I
think is going to be fun so so do it
we'll try to like I don't know call into
a couple of these and say hi but um this
is cool so that's happening next week
that's fun go meet some other people who
um are part of neckbeard nation um and
then what do you think is that a thing
um number two uh we're doing the poker
tournament so a while back we talked
about this business that we thought
found fascinating which was a cloud
poker tournament it's like his digital
poker tournament where everybody's
webcams on it could be private for our
community and uh 300 or 400 people
signed up we just never scheduled it but
now we scheduled it it's December 13th
it's happening uh we will give away
merch and some cool stuff as prizes
we'll come up with some dope prizes
maybe like you know whatever thousand
bucks or a call or free merch or
whatever um so yeah it's at Cloud poern
knight.com so cloudporn night.com MFM so
if you want to register for that if you
already registered we'll send out an
email uh to be able letting them know
that that's happening uh and last thing
is I do a thing every year which is I uh
this month this month of December is the
plan for you know other people are
thinking about Christmas I'm thinking
about end of your next year hit my goals
and so I basically use this time for
planning for 2024 so uh I'm GNA host a
free session which basically is I I'm
currently doing it for all my businesses
I make like a one-page plan for what I'm
trying to do next year and it's
basically like the big goal and then the
breakdown of like how I'm going to do it
I have a method of how I get to that
answer and you walk away with kind of
like a clear one pager for your business
uh Ben had the idea he was like dude I
love when we do this he's like we should
just like do this together with other
people that own businesses that want to
do it and so um yeah people want to do
it I'm just going to be on a zoom and
I'll walk you through my process totally
free uh you'll walk away in an hour with
like a bunch of clarity on what's what
your next year looks like uh I have a
bunch of good questions that help people
get clarity so if you want to attend
that um plan for20 24.com so go to plan
for2 24.com uh Ben's going to spin up a
website and we'll we'll invite people to
that um if you're the type of person
that wants to kind of like set the
vision and the intention for next year I
like that one he also had another line
Munger did where he's like I never try
to disagree with someone's opinion
unless I've under unless I understand
their side better than they do right and
and that's like a specific example of
like let's say debate of how he was like
I need to I need to deserve this right
so that's number two I love that one he
says I'm not entitled to an opinion like
I can't have conviction until I can
argue the other side better than someone
who believes the other side and he's
like he's like people think he's like
people think this is some like crazy
high bar and those people haven't ever
asked somebody who believes something
why they believe it like it's actually
quite a low bar to surpass their own
like con their own understanding of
something um and you know I think about
this with like Bitcoin for example I'm a
Bitcoin believer and my approach to this
was always to say here's all the reason
reasons why I believe in Bitcoin it just
makes sense for you know reason a b c
and d but actually the better way to do
is to say smart people who don't believe
in Bitcoin would say a b and c and I
understand that and here's what I think
about those and why I've landed on the
side of conviction that I have it's just
a much better logical way to think than
to just say here's what I believe and
I'm going to come up with all the
evidence I'm even going to make up some
of it to justify my opinion which is I
would say how steel Manning yeah so
steel Manning is like argue the other
side better than they would even argue
it um so one of my favorite I'll bring
up one uh good line but I uh whenever I
hear about these like freaks I call them
Freaks and I mean that in in in a ad
admirable way I like when they're on the
birkshire Hathaway Podium giving their
speech they're basically set up like a
comedian in order to like give these
beautiful lines what I try to find is
just weird dated day quirks that they
have and like ways that they're acting
on a day-to-day basis and so I've got
you know our good friend Jack like when
I'm with them he'll be like oh I didn't
name my daughter I was like why he was
like well I need to get to know her
first um you know we're I'm gonna wait
to name her so she's just named baby for
now but once we get to know her and I'm
like that's so weird and then you start
thinking about it like that's actually
not weird it is kind of weird to name a
human being before you got to got to
meet her so that's like an example like
in every day one of my one of our
friends Jack wildly successful he's been
successful in odd ways and you see how
he acts and daily life there's this cool
uh story from I think it's called making
of an American capitalist and so they
talk about how here I'll read just this
part from the book they go physically
Munger was unimpressive he had an
elf-like face pacy skin and glasses an
inch thick though something of though
though something of a snob and highly
Jud judgmental he had a deep sense of
ethics and his smarts were matched by
churchillian self
assurance once uh he was asked if he
could play the piano and Munga replied I
don't know I've never tried and I
thought
like what a telling line like what a
telling lie so most people you say no I
can't play the piano this was I probably
could it's there's definitely potential
that I will be a great piano player I
just haven't tried and when I read that
line I I just thought this man's
beautiful this man's one of a kind and I
love people like that because myself you
most everyone we default to can you do
this it's like of course not I I don't
have the capabilities I I I cannot do
that where that little mind shift of
like well not yet dude even noticing
that props to you I read that line in
the research I didn't even understand
what was remarkable with the line I just
moved on I didn't even notice it till
you just said it like you did uh so good
on you for even observing it that's a
good one well that's what I'm saying
when I'm reading about these guys it's
like these little one-off lines or these
like like for example they'll say he
found founded this law firm and then
next he was bored there next like
whatever and I'm like well hold on let
me go look at this law firm and then you
start reading about this law firm and
like dude this is quirky this is a weird
super strange law firm and so anyway
yeah this line it's a beautiful line uh
about just showing like the day-to-day
about how you can be different let me
give you number four so my number four
um Charlie ISM I want to bring up is let
me tell you a little story about where I
where I felt this first and I'm going
tell you the Charlie ISM so let's rewind
the clock 15 years I was living in
Indonesia and in Indonesia I lived in
this building that had a ping pong table
and I don't know anybody because I'm
living in Jakarta Indonesia I don't have
any friends there and so I used to go
down and just hang out by the ping pong
table because I thought well that's
maybe like you know my equivalent of
like going having a drink at the bar
let's just go see if anybody's down here
to play and maybe I can meet some people
and uh so sure enough I would go down me
and my brother-in-law we would go down
and we would play and my brother-in-law
is better than me at pingpong and
he the way he plays is what you imagine
somebody who's good at pingpong I would
serve and he would hit back but like we
would get to this point where he would
hit like a smash and my brother-in-law
is kind of a character if you've ever
met him he's like he's not just gonna
hit it fast he's gonna jump even though
you don't need to jump he's gonna be
like w but he's gonna just make you feel
like he just smashed this shot and like
I was so like I was trying to get better
than him he was trying to get better
than me and I thought okay he's just got
higher skill he's more advanced he's
brilliant at this like he could just hit
these amazing shots and I got to be able
to hit amazing shots so I'm practicing
hitting amazing shots and he and so
whoever used to come down he would beat
them he was the best guy in the building
until one day this 55 60y old man came
down named Poppy uh oh and we're like
your name is Poppy he's like I'm poppy
we're like okay I don't know if he's bit
flexing on us if this is a real name and
he takes a a paddle out of his um of his
like case and we're like oh dude he's
got his own his own paddle oh it's
like the guy who brings his on bowling
ball to the bowling alley you know this
guy means business so so we already on
on like aame basically and so uh I play
him and Poppy beats me but he didn't do
anything like he wasn't smashing the
ball he wasn't doing it and I just
thought oh man I was off today all right
like Aaron you play him and so I have my
brother-in-law Aaron play him I'm like
all right Aaron's never lost to anybody
in this building let's see what happens
and he starts playing Poppy and he's
trying to do what he always does he's
trying to hit brilliant shots on the
corner down the line crosscourt you know
drop shot and none of it's working poppy
is destroying him and the way that Poppy
plays is like this is for anybody who's
like a real ping pong fan I need like
something to demonstrate so use this pen
Pretend This is the paddle normally when
you play ping pong your arm is back
you're doing like a full stroke like a
tennis thing just looking dope he used
to just hold it like this forward like
the paddle just facing you and then he
would just move left and right like a
wall and he would just whatever you hit
he would just hit back and the thing
about poy is poy was never hitting
brilliant shots but he would also never
hit it out and never hit the net and so
inevitably he would just keep hitting it
back and one of your brilliant shots
would go out of bounds you would hit it
too hard too soft You' hit the net like
you would mess up and he would always
score based on your error and he crushed
us and he crushed us that day and he
crushed us every day and he would just
chuckle and say good game and he would
go upstairs and we'd be like
poppy man I'm gonna get this guy and we
never got him the whole summer I was
there we never one time beat this guy
and then one day he invited us up to his
house afterward his apartment in the
building he lived in the penthouse
beautiful he was so successful in
business we're like poppy dude you're
balling out of control he had like a
secret poker room he had a a wall of
just like super fancy Like Liquor like
people have a wine seller he had like a
fancy liquor wall it was crazy he had a
shower with like six showerheads and we
were like dude this guy poppy this and
we're like What do you do and he's like
I sell soap
and we're like you're like you make soap
he's like no no I just Import and Export
and we're like is it better soap he's
like no it's just soap um he's like it's
good soap it's not the best and we were
like well who how do you sell it he's
like well I just go to people that need
soap and we're like this poppy
like this is how he lives his life too
he's just making no no brilliant shots
but no unforced errors and so this is a
Charlie merism which is avoiding
stupidity is easier than seeking
Brilliance and he says other people
spend their whole life trying to be so
smart all I'm trying to do is not be
idiotic it's harder than people think
but this is more important than trying
to be brilliant and so Charlie was
basically like how do I just avoid the
great errors in life let's say it's
investing how do I avoid the great
errors of investing if it's Health how
do I avoid the great errors of health
and that's basically what he oriented
around he wasn't perfect at it but I
thought what a totally different you
know a different strategy than you'll
ever hear which is about being the best
and becoming more advanced and becoming
you know being brilliant and talented
and his thing was just just avoid
stupidity and you you'll outperform
everybody is there a category in the
Oscars for like podcasters who can weave
in a story into Charlie Munger if if if
yes I think you might get I think you
might get that nod that was a wonderful
we got to give it up that was a
wonderful you you you had being
enthralled and I didn't know where you
were going to go with this I didn't know
where I was going to
go you just open your mouth and start
talking and see where it goes and you
won that Mr wonder you you you totally
won that one that was a beautiful
beautiful way to tie that in
copyrighting that's what that's what
that was well honestly the reason why
today there's going to be literally a
thousand threads that are Charlie Munger
was live till 99 here's 99 lessons I
learned and they're going to regurgitate
the stupid quotes in Wikipedia but this
is my first we do things differently
around here we're not just going to give
you the regurgitated quotes I got to
give you that you know little special je
that old je that you could dip that
sandwich
in well you came with he that's going to
be hard to compete with I um Let me let
me ask you something so right now it's
uh it's November 29th so most people are
doing their next year financial planning
for their businesses for years at the
hustle I made a very similar mistake
that I bet you made and that is over
optimism have you ever hit any of your
project in the first six years of your
career never I've never met a goal I've
ever set
yeah dude if you ask people at the
hustle like one of my big weaknesses is
is it's looking at the numbers of the
Excel sheet and you know you see like a
seven million here uh and you're like
what if we took that seven and deleted
it and put a
nine I'm like look how much more profit
they gave us let's just do that a genius
yeah that's basically people would be
driven crazy because that's what I would
do I would just look at the sheets I'm
like yeah that looks good but hey look
if you just delete that number and put
it to that number look how much better
this looks so let's just do that and
I've made that mistake so many times I
um I bought a property uh recently or a
few years back and I remember like
thinking like okay this is only an okay
price property but yeah you know I I'm
going to like take better pictures or
I'm going to like do something when I
sell it and I'm going to make that's how
I'm going to make all this money is I'm
just going to increase revenue and I'm
I'm going to do this this this and guess
what just like years of failing at
projecting I totally effed it up so now
I try to be way more modest uh with my
financial projections but I but I
completely uh have always messed it up
and uh munger's got a bunch of good
quotes he's like it's dangerous to rely
too much a models and formula the the
reality is way more complex than that
and he says um we're very disciplined in
our approach and we're not and we're not
swayed by flimsy optimism and then he
goes on to say he's like uh where's the
exact quote he talks about how um he
basically says like it's pretty
ridiculous that people are are biased by
both uh over skep skepticism and over
optimism in in the business world if the
micro reality is good good decisions and
good systems are what I look for I don't
I don't use predict or not predictions
of macro environment changes and so
basically the point being is his whole
philosophy was to buy businesses where
if I bought a good business at a good
price I'm golden and then if I ever want
to sell it or if something crazy
improves that's icing on the cake
whereas what I do and I bet most people
do and I try my hardest to avoid this
nowadays is I say I default to no the
optimism is actually the truth the truth
is just that's just what they did
because they don't know what the hell
they're talking about you know what I
mean right and that's been one of my
biggest mistakes in business is over
optimis or uh over optimism and what it
does is it crushes team morale and it
gets you in a losing state of mind and
it just sucks um what what Munger said
was he goes you make a lot of money on
when you buy a good company at a good
price but you make all of the money by
letting it ride for 20 years so the
patience is where the big money is and I
struggle like crazy to do that I have
this this year we're I'm trying to a
little bit differently but I have never
hit any of my projections because it's
just too optimistic and that is B it's
basically just mental masturbation Is
What It Is by by making these
projections and it's harmful it's it's a
liability well there's like there's like
the the thing you want to hit you know
some people say you want to hit 70% of
the goals um that you that you set and
that's like the right balance between
ambition and um you know practicality
you know zero hitting 0% of your goals
is obviously means you're setting the
wrong goals and hitting 100% of your
goals means you're you know obviously
being playing it too safe and
conservatively and so there is some
number in between you can pick 70 50 60
whatever works for you and uh yeah I
think most entrepreneurs and investors
for that matter are on the side of
optimism because boy doesn't it feel
better in the moment to uh to be
optimistic do you want to know something
I'm trying to do no goals I'm trying to
do no goals and I it's it's not working
out with any of the partners who I'm
involved with who are trying to fight
this you know what it's not doing
working out yeah I'm trying no goals and
I'm getting no no Buy in
so I hate i' I've grown to hate goals
man like it shouldn't change but this is
like your thing with money do you have
like a you have like a weird
relationship with money that you need
like money therapy you have probably
like a weird relationship with goals
that like uh you just need to work out
like you know these extremes you know
crazy goals that nobody can hit or no
goals like you know I would just assume
that the answer is actually somewhere in
the middle right theism is probably
somewhere somewhere in the middle not
not either extreme the analogy that I
would give people is like let's say you
say bolt is in the Olympics in the 100
meter dash and he runs this race like it
doesn't matter if he if if we timed the
race a he won and B like just tracking
that that time like he he ran faster
than everyone else who cares who cares
what the you know who who who cares
about that stuff and so I'm like it
doesn't matter so compare yourself to
others is the answer
instead well we're talking about Munger
and these guys were the analogy Kings
man come on um in this analogy you're
you saying bolt correct yeah okay
good I just I I get fed up with overt
tracking and over planning so like we're
you know Hampton is uh 18 months old
let's say 12 months old and we're trying
to look at so they want to plan 12
months out and I'm like yeah that's 50%
of the company's existence let's go to
one of his other ones that I think is
kind of related which is one of munger's
Big Ideas the one one that he is is well
known for that I have taken into my life
is this idea of inversion so he he says
invert always invert and so you know
that what does this mean it's basically
a way to Think Through problems
backwards so if you let's say you wanted
to solve a common thing that people ask
which is you know how do I be successful
um or how do I be happy in life and
there might be like a thousand different
answers to that question but what Munger
would do is is in order to get to the
answer faster he would invert right why
does Bill Gates say he goes from A to Z
faster than anyone he's has the best 30
second brain of anyone it's because
munger's default way of problem solving
is to invert and so he'll say instead of
figuring out how to be happy let me just
figure out what is the sure Surefire
path to misery and he literally wrote it
out like I can read you the answer what
he said is the Sure Fire path to misery
or what what what did he say uh okay so
his his prescri he he actually did a
talk and he calls this say prescription
for misery so he says um what a be what
a beautiful line by the way is that
beautiful language or what it is it's
wonderful and he says um in you know
number one ingesting chemicals to alter
your mood or perception so if you rely
on chemicals to change your mood
eventually this leads to misery this is
like you know alcoholism or like sort of
like over stimulation whatnot um number
two is Envy uh he has this great quote
which is the world is not people think
the world is driven by greed it's
actually driven by Envy uh he goes um
you know I'm lucky that you know I'm an
old man now and I've conquered my Envy I
don't give a damn what anybody else has
I don't want one anybody else has and I
don't care what they have uh but most
people are not like that for most people
it drives them up the walls if they see
that the neighbor has a nicer car or
that their friend has a higher paying
job or that their cooworker gets
promoted they didn't even want it in the
first place but as soon as somebody else
has it Envy kicks in and it drives them
it drives you know so much of their
behavior and so number two of the
prescription for for misery is Envy
third related is resentment if uh if
your joy goes down when other people's
Joy goes up that is a Surefire way to
have a miserable life so those are three
that he stole from somebody else and he
saids I'd like to add my four on top of
that he says um number four be
unreliable uh if you are unre unreliable
you will be distrusted by all those who
matter and that you might be a mighty
fine Turtle but you will be outrun by
hordes of mediocre turtles if you are
unreliable and even some turtles that
are on crutches so it's like this idea
that uh you know availability is the
best ability that that if you are
unreliable it sort of cancels out any
talent that you have that one hit home
for me because as you know I am a bit of
an unreliable person and I've have paid
the price for that in many many times
yeah hey by the way should we bring up
that uh MFM podcast meeting that you
missed yesterday yeah just was on a
different call and forgot about it and
so these things happen and it is a
penalty I pay it is part of my
prescription for misery um here's the
next one so he says another number five
is learn only from your own experience
and your own uh you know trials
basically um if you decide that your
firstand experience is your only way to
figure out good versus bad and you're
not going to learn from other living and
dead people uh that is a Surefire way to
misery because you will you will learn
much slower than than somebody who who
learns the other way um next one he goes
when hit with adversity go down and stay
down that's another prescription for
misery is to not bounce back from
adversity the INE the the inevitable and
unavoidable blows of life and the last
one he goes don't be objective stay
stuck in your ways hold on to your
initial ideas your most loved ideas hold
them with a death grip and that is his
final prescription for misery is to uh
to never change your mind in light of
new
facts my um of those that you mentioned
my biggest weaknesses are Envy so this
pod is fun for you and I to do sometimes
it creates a lot of Envy because have
all these amazing people on here or or
if it's just you and I like Sean just
did great uh Sam didn't do as good or uh
if we have all these amazing people on
and you start talking to them and you're
like huh I'm just as smart as this guy
but this guy how do you know because
when you ask how old are you that's the
that's the trigger of like I'm feeling
terrible can you really just do the
finishing blow and tell me that you're
two years younger than
me yeah like we have so many and every
once in a while there are people uh who
I'm like yeah you're just better
so Zillo people's houses after you uh
after you see them that's not really
nothing good happens on the end of a
Zillow so I have um I've got I I read I
read a lot and I I like reading
biographies and whenever I read a
biography I do sort of what I did up
here where I write down like let's say
it's a business biography I'll write
down the years and I'll make notes of
interesting things that happened to that
person in that year and then if it
involves a dollar amount I'll write the
dollar amount and then in one sell over
I'll say what's that dollar amount in
today's numbers and then I'll say how
old were they and so I'm like reverse
engineering different people's lives but
you know what I'm really doing I'm
comparing myself to yeah of course I'm
comparing myself to them you're running
that race except for you're not Usain
Bolt you're Tyson Gay and you're
watching Usain Bolt in front of you and
I justify it by saying uh uh like if I
read someone and I am better off than
they than they are uh I say great I'm
doing better than them and they ended up
wonderfully I'm going to end up
wonderfully or if they're kicking my ass
at my age I just think mother this
sucks I got to give you credit for your
honesty and vulnerability because you're
being honest and vulnerable admitting
this but I do not advise anybody follow
this game plan this is a recipe fory not
saying that this is I'm not saying this
is helpful I'm just admitting and and
the last thing that I sort of suck at is
being bendable what what was the last
one what did how did he Des he's like
you know um don't be objective uh don't
change your don't change your mind you
know stay stuck in your way stay stuck
in hold on to those Initial Ideas you
had before these new new facts and
circumstances came
out yeah I I you know I uh I try to
think of myself as bendable but I could
work on that for sure the ones that I uh
struggle with out of this are the
unreliable one for sure and then um
maybe Envy as second one I think that's
probably like number two I think I'm
pretty good on all these other ones
that's interesting I would I I I
wouldn't have thought by the way of you
as an envious person I think that's a
hard one to kick uh you know I don't
think I'm like let's say uh terrible at
it but it's definitely there it's not
something that I could be like yeah I
have conquered that mountain no no no
I'm still somewhere on that mountain hey
do you know what the uh what I think
it's the 61th Commandment is thou sh not
Thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
right right don't be jealous don't be
jealous my friend
so if I said this joke it's going to get
me in trouble with at least five people
at minimum in my life so I'm just going
to not make this joke all right so um I
want to give you some examples of the
invert principle because I think this is
one of the most important ones so when
he was a military meteorologist it's
World War II his job is to keep pilot
safe and he's like okay uh what What's
everything I need to know about pilot
safety and he's like you know there's
like seven textbooks about everything a
pilot needs to know and then instead
he's like no no no okay let's work
backwards what are the most likely
causes of of crashes or in for pilots
and he went and studied that way simpler
answer he's like okay I just need to be
able to predict snow ice and fog really
well as a military meteorologist those
three if I can avoid if I can get my
Pilots out of the way of those three uh
I can ignore everything else because
those three are the the real killers and
let me like so he inverted in order to
like do his job let me tell you another
example of this when I was in college um
I got picked as part of some like thing
called chyos that was like uhr top
College startups in the country honestly
it was like worse than Forbes 30 under
30 in terms of like credibility
literally if you signed up you won and
um even better if you signed up you won
and then you you uh made friends with
the person they would take you on this
all expenses paid trip to China for a
week to go meet uh Jack ma the CEO of
Alibaba or the founder of Alibaba and so
we go I get picked on this trip I go fly
to China I don't even know what Alibaba
is we go to their headquarters I'm like
holy this is like eBay for China or
something this is crazy and uh we get a
sit down meeting with the CEO this guy's
like one of the most powerful people in
China and somebody as you know we got to
ask questions one of the kids ask you
know the S simpleton question like you
know what's your advice you know I want
to be successful what's your advice like
what are what are the keys to success
from your experience and um and he says
uh you know I was obsessed with this
question also what are the keys to
success what is the blueprint for
success and I talked to 100 successful
people and I got a 100 different
Blueprints and I thought thought well
that doesn't really help and this is
Jack uh this was actually a guy named
David we I think is his name he was the
current CEO at the time he was the one
answering this part and he goes um he
goes every success is different it's its
own little unique snowflake but every
failure is the same and we were like you
know we lean in and you know he had his
answer and his answer I don't think is
actually the right answer but for this
but like he goes um it like tied into
the Alibaba story and he goes every
every every big company that that
eventually fails so his his answer was
like not how to be successful but how do
you not screw it up once you're a big
company which was the problem they were
having he goes too much money too much
technology and too many people and so he
tells a story about like how they were
going to compete with um with Google and
with eBay when they were coming to China
and he's like we needed to invent our
version of Google AdWords and he goes
Jack ma said cool you get um I think it
was like 125 people he's like 125 people
this is like going to be a huge part of
the business Google has 2,000 people
working on this he goes did I stutter
you get 12 to 15 people uh you're going
to work um he's like we need some office
space uh you know give us like a couple
floors of the office or whatever he's
like you're going to work out of my old
apartment he's like your old apartment
we need a proper office he goes I
started Alibaba in that apartment I
think it'll work and he goes uh
technology is like you know we're going
to need this many servers we should get
the best stuff uh and you know we need
this much but let's have double that for
redundancy in case you know the servers
go down we don't want to lose anything
he goes if I give you redundant servers
you're going to design a system that
goes down I'm going to give you only the
servers you need and in fact uh you go
get go get used servers so it can run on
even shitty servers and you know he sort
of David goggin them that was like the
story that he told about like and they
they eventually did it they pulled it
off but I wonder if that guy found that
inspiring at first or like what the
Jack it was definitely like a you
man come on but uh you know when it all
works out then you can tell this great
story um basos has a simple inversion
too they were like you know Jeff Tech
you're you're you know one of the like
internet CEOs internet's evolving so
fast technolog is always changing what
technology Innovations are you most
excited for what's going to change about
Amazon in 10 years and he goes oh I
don't think about that instead I think
about what's not going to change he go
customers are always going to want the
most selection the lowest prices and the
fastest delivery and so everything else
can change but that's not going to
change and so we focus on what's not
going to change because we have to
change with the times in order to like
constantly beat cons customers
expectations on delivery speeds low
prices and and vast selection and so you
know this idea of inversion is so
powerful even in my own like life I was
telling you like I'm having a bunch of U
progress right now with my diet which is
great because like you know the
scoreboard is currently 3 you know 34
years of no progress and you know like a
month of great progress right now well
what changed and well I did a bunch of
things but but I also actually just
inverted so instead of trying to figure
out what's the best diet program what's
the best workout program exactly how
many grams of of this how many
milligrams of creatine how many grams of
protein how much how much of this
instead of trying to like go is it the
Paleo keto diet Mediterranean diet what
should I be doing it was just the
inversion like what's a Surefire way to
be fat and that answer was quite simple
like I need to eat way more I'm gonna
burn um eating shitty foods that are
fried and ultr processed um you know
right now I eat late at night pretty
sure that's a recipe to get fat um you
know sitting all day instead of walking
for my meetings probably pretty good way
to get fat is to sit all day and I just
inverted and I was like okay cool I'm
just going to walk more I'm gonna you
know eat less calories than I consume
and I'm gonna um not late night snack
because I always eat crappy food when I
do that this literally all I changed and
like boom like started to get results
finally after like you know instead of
like being like let me go download 19
hours of Andrew huberman and try to like
follow this protocol it's like that
wasn't the problem right like that that
was the complex solution rather than the
the easy
inversion that's great um let's do a
couple more do you have any other ones
that you like here I I have a story he
told that I thought was pretty cool
let's wrap up with that story all right
so he's uh he's teaching a class at some
college he goes to like an economics
class and he's like um so he has this
general idea of you need to learn all
the big ideas in a space so he's like I
don't know anything about psychology but
I figur there's probably 20 Big Ideas in
the world of of psychology and I should
just like read the books and try to
figure out what are your what are the 20
Big Ideas in your space he's like if I
know those 20 Big Ideas I'm going to be
better than like I'll know more than 98%
of people who spent their whole life you
know 0% of people including some people
who spend their whole life doing this
because they're so lost in the weeds and
so one of the big Ideas he had was like
so he goes into economics same thing
what are the Big Ideas in economics
everybody knows like economics 101 is
the supply demand curve and uh you know
basically the the idea is that you know
as the you know um you know supply of
something goes down the demand will go
up or the price will go up similarly if
you drop the price of something the
demand should go up so like people know
this generally about
economics is but Charlie has a thing
he's like you learned the big idea but
then you also how do you make this
useful is you need to understand the
exceptions to those rules so what is the
i before e except after C so he's like
how do you understand that okay
generally when prices go down demand
should go up for that you know the
demand for TVs is let's say you know X
at $5,000 but if you drop the price of a
TV down to $5 there's a lot of people
that will buy it and so he's like but
what are the exceptions so he goes into
this economics class and he goes
everybody understands you know when
prices go down demand goes everybody
says up he says okay fantastic what are
the cases where that's not true so let
me just put you on the spot as if you're
one of the students so what's a case
where that's not true where the opposite
happens an item that is supposed to uh
signal Prestige exactly so hands go up
50 hands go up and they say luxury Goods
uh any item where price is a signal for
quality or status um and he's like you
know this is luxury hand bags and
whatnot you know if a Louis Vuitton bag
was $2 tomorrow the demand would
actually you know briefly go up but then
in the long term go down and um he's
like so everybody gets that one and he
goes what
else and now you get crickets right
like what else and he goes um he
goes
any industry where demand is based on
bribing the
purchaser he goes what he goes yeah
there's like many Industries the defense
industry uh me many parts of the the
medical industry where actually it's a
screwed up kind of perverse incentives
where companies take profits and they
use those to um you know shower you know
Goods or or or money or um experiences
on buying agents purchasers and um
whether that's through advertisement so
like I spend a ton of money advertising
and that's how I create the demand and
if I didn't have any advertising budget
I wouldn't be able to create the demand
or it's things like the you know um the
the military industrial complex where
there's like some cronyism where it's
like yeah you give me this contract
today because in five years you're going
to be on my board and your retirement
package will be 10 times what you're
making in the government and because we
all know that that's true because I have
so much excess profit you want to reward
me with big contracts and actually you
want to pay more for these contracts so
that we can be this really successful
company because it rewards you in the
end um and he's like once you realize
that that's an exception to this rule
you will understand how the world
actually works you will understand where
the laws of gravity actually break and I
just love that story I think it told
like it's an interesting Little Nugget
business-wise but also the way that
capitalism works but it's also shows
kind of the way this guy thinks which is
this i before e except after C mentality
where he goes into any space he tries to
speedrun and figure out you know what
are the 10 to 20 Big Ideas of your space
and then he looks at the exceptions and
um you know I did this recently I was I
went to Brian Johnson's house and
afterwards I was like think about
longevity and I was like all right
should I be one of these Tech guys that
like really cares about
longevity like has longevity gonna be my
or am I gonna zag and be like
longevity overrated and I was like I
need to have an opinion and I decided
what would Munger say hey Munger lived
to be
99 he didn't look like a longevity freak
well somebody said this well V said this
he goes Buffett and Munger these guys
are like in their 90s and uh you know
they famously like you know eat
McDonald's breakfast every day and you
know eat you know M&M's and drink Diet
Cokes maybe for show but you know they
at least do it they're not sitting there
taking metformin and like cold plunging
every morning and uh he's like you know
it just goes to show how um how
important like not being stressed is
actually to your health yeah uh because
these guys actually were quite low
stress in the way that they they lived
their life you know SP most of their
days reading playing bridge Talking
thinking uh very few meetings they
didn't sort of like you know stress out
about Investments they were Buy and Hold
long-term investor type of thing like
low stress compared to a lot of uh
successful people um but on the
longevity thing I was like all right let
me go learn what are the 10 Big Ideas in
the longevity space and I literally
carved out two days and me and Ben all
we did was just Deep dive into longevity
like I read I read like power skimmed
through some books I read I I I was like
who are the five like thought leaders
and what are their most popular TED
talks and like let me go watch those let
me go see what these you know what does
petera say what does Brian Johnson say
what what are like the quotes so what's
your takeaway of all of it my takeaway
was that the big ideas and this is like
somebody who's a big longevity person
will will argue with me because I'm
going to do the short version of this
but the big idea is essentially
everybody in Everybody's Health declines
we are probably past the age of like the
live forever so there's like one big
idea which is that if we ever figure out
a way way to reverse aging or like
minimize cell
damage um it's not just going to be this
gradual thing like we used to live till
80 then 90 then 100 then 110 120 130
it's going to be like there's going to
be a stepf jump once we figure out how
to stop cell damage but if you've
already had too much damage they're not
going to be able to like get you back
into your 20s you're going to be like
past the point of return and so like the
big breakthrough is if you can figure
out how to stop sell damage we don't
know how to do that yet when that
happens there's going to be an age sort
of point a Tipping Point where people
below that are going to live to like 300
and people above that are still going to
live to like 110 and like there's gonna
be this big like disper you know polar
you know polarity between those two
outcomes that's interesting the second
interesting thing is like in terms of
the Peter AA school of thought of
longevity which is not live forever but
it's like live a longer Health span so
Health span versus lifespan is one big
idea and the health span idea is at the
end of your life everybody's going to
have a marginal decade which is like
your last 10 years of life your your
health is going to decline pretty
dramatically from like being immobile
and pain and in pain to like you know
really you know not being able to wipe
your butt by the end right so it's like
that's typically the like bad version of
Aging what Peter T and these guys are
trying to do is basically push that
decade out so if it was going to happen
to you from 80 to 90 let's make it from
90 to 100 or if it was gonna happen 90
to 100 let's 100 to
110 and the cost of your today lifestyle
in order to affect that final marginal
decade I personally was like H not worth
it I'm gonna find the 8020 of like
healthy things to do that are not so
costly like not so painful or hard to
follow or like regimented or whatever
like I'm not going to forget to live
today in order for my age 90 to 100 to
be like better um I will take the
instant gratification please and so I
was like you know my takeaway was
basically I don't care about the
marginal decade I'm not going to orient
my life around that there's an8 20 of
like healthier stuff to do that's like h
i don't mind switching to that lifestyle
I'll do those and then that's good
enough for me and if like you know
Wonder drugs come out in some point in
the future hopefully I'm in time for
that cut off that was my conclusion do
you think that Buffett is gonna die like
next week now that like is this like a
you know like an old couple that they
die together yeah is that like that very
well might happen he uh I think he
Buffett announced recently they like I I
he's like I I finally found my successor
at the age of 92 i' I've found my
um all right well that's the Pod before
we go if you made it this far Sean I
want to tell you the people in the
YouTube comments have been making fun of
you and I what they are saying that I
dress like a serial killer which I don't
know what that means entirely or that I
now that I'm a father I'm starting to
dress like a father or look like an
accountant and they're making fun of
your hair I don't exactly know what
they're making a fun about your hair cuz
I think you've got great hair well no I
looked at that video and I was like
I'm also looking exclusively at my hair
in that I had a bad I had a bad hair day
in the sense that I wake up roll out of
bed I do this podcast right away and I
don't even look in the mirror and um
dude I'm like the hairiest guy on earth
like I got hair on my Palms like
I'm like a you know like a a gorilla and
somehow I think I'm losing kind of some
hair in the front I'm getting a little
light and uh people were like yo he's
got to start taking um whatever the drug
is called I forgot what it is but like
so to all the
commenters go f yourselves right we're
just doing our thing well I don't care
what other people think of me unless
it's related to my looks or my
intelligence and um so I did go ahead
and and and wet the hair a little bit
today and uh you know try to try to
Spruce it
up it does hurt my feelings too
sometimes if I'm being
honest but besides that you're gonna
hear me say oh I don't read the comments
it doesn't bother me hey but you know
what's what's working sha P my little
Gary ve branding pivot is kind of
working in the comments every day
they're like sha P sha P for president
and uh right now we're a small but loyal
Army I don't think anyone said sha B for
president there's a small but loyal
Army there's as they said in Arrested
Development there's tens of us out there
and uh but but it is from that small
base that we shall grow Sean P it is all
right that's the
[Music]
pod